[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد بعد الاعلان عن
وفاه ابراهيم منير القائمه بعمل مرشد
الجماعه وقائد جبهه لندن تواجه جماعه
الاخوان المزيد من الانقسام والتشدي داخل
جبهاته المنشقى محللون يرون ان وفاه منير
ارجلت حسنه خلاف جماعهه مع المنوئين له في
جبهه محمود حسين كما يحسب على منير انه
فشله فتواصل مع الاخوان في مصر فلا يمكن
للجماعه ان تكون قويه من دون اخوان مصر
وهو ما اعطى في المقابل قوه لمحمود حسين
وجبهتها ويرى المتابعون للجماعه انه مع
تولي محي الدين الظاهره المهمه الاداريه
لجماعه الاخوان الارهابيه بعد وفاه
ابراهيم منير ستجعل من المنافسه ورهان على
استمرار الخصومه بصوره التي كانت في حياتي
منير صعبه ومستحيلات حيث يبدو محد زين
الظاهر الشخص الضعيف في مواجهه حسين حيث
يعتبر الاول على من الثاني فبينما كان
الاول عضوا لمجلس شور الجماعه كما ثاني
عضوي مكتب الارشاد والامين العام للجماعه
لذلك يرى محللون انه ليس امام جبهته
ابراهيم منير الا محاوله حسم نقاط الخلاف
مع جبهه المناوئه جبهه محمود حسين وهذا
يبدو تحقيقه صعب المنال ولكنه وارد بحسب
كاتبنا
قلت بحسبي كتبنا لان هذا الموضوع سنقشره
استنادا على ما كتبه ضيفنا سنناقش هذا
الموضوع مع اولا من الرياض هدى الصالح
الكتبه صحفيه وكاتب المقال من القاهره
منير اديب الباحث في شؤون الجماعات
المتطرفه اهلا بكم
الكريمين واسمح لي ان ابدا من القاهره معك
مع كاتب هذا المقال الذي استندنا على
التفاصيل التي حاولنا ان نفهمها في الواقع
ولكن الاستاذ منير حضرتك في العنوان
الكبير لهذا المقال ربطه وفاه ابراهيم
منير بجماعه الاخوان عموما باستمرار ها من
عدمه ولكن لما قرات المقال همم يعني
انتظرت للخير لاخر همم فقره في المقال
لاجد هذا الربط كل المقال تحدثت فيه عن
همم الجبهه الثانيه وكانك تود القول بان
هذه الجزيئات قد تكون كذلك في ضغطها في
اهميتها على نفس القدر من الاهميه مع
الجماعه هل هذا موادد قوله
نعم اهلا وسهلا بك يا استاذه ريم مشاهدينك
الكرام وبضيفتك الكريمه ايضا يعني لا شك
ان هذا المقال انا حاولت ان ارصد فيه واقع
التنظيم وانعكاس وفاه الرجل الاول في
التنظيم ابراهيم منير خاصه وان ابراهيم
منير كان نائبا لمرشد الاخوان وفق نص
لائحه عندما كان مرشد الاخوان وهمم
الاخوان
يختارون باريحيه شديده مكتب الارشاد ومن
ثم ان وافق كان ابراهيم منير نائبا
للاخوان ممثلا للخارج وبالتالي بعد وفاه
ابراهيم منير ربما تحطمت همم اي احاديث
لها علاقه
باللائحه الداخليه للاخوان التي يتم على
اثرها خليفه لابراهيم منير فضلا عن انعكاس
ما حدث من وفاه ابراهيم منير على الجبه
مناوي كان هناك حديث على ان ابراهيم منير
وقد قال ابراهيم منير في لقاء تنظيمي منذ
ثلاثه اشهر لانصاري استبشروا خيرا سوف
يكون هناك امر جديد يتعلق همم وضع الاخوان
في لندن وهنا وفق المعلومات التي وصلت لنا
كان هناك تواصل من قبل اجهزه استخبارات
دوليه مع ابراهيم منير قالت له نصا سوف
ننحاز الى جبهه لندن في مواجهه جبهه
اسطنبول ومن ثم ابلغ ابراهيم منير هذه
الرساله لان صالح حتى ان اغلب التقارير
التي كتبت كتبت على ان جبهه لندن شبه حسمت
هذا الخلاف بعد وفاه ابراهيم منير انقلب
الامر راسا على عقب لاسباب لها علاقه بان
هناك هناك
في لائحه الداخليه للاخوان هذا النص يقول
انه في حاله وفاه المرش يتولى احد نوابي
وفي حاله وفاه همم نائب المرشد يتولى اكبر
الاعضاء سنا وبما ان محمود حسين الذي
يتولى اا الجبهه المناوئه هو عضو مكتب
الارشاد الوحيد الموجود خارج السجون ومن
ثم وفق نص اللائحه يتولى محمود حسين شؤون
التنظيم وهذا وضع جبهه ابراهيم منير في
حركه شديد فضلا على ان انه لا يوجد لا
يوجد بديل ابراهيم منير داخل
الجبهاتي لي اسباب لها علاقه يعني ابراهيم
منير
سيقول قال بان ابراهيم منير همم وهنا سؤال
لحضرتك استاذه هدى همم ليس على نفس القدر
من الثقه والاهميه مع محمود حسين هذا اولا
همم يعني جبهه لندن تبدو اضعف من جبه
اسطنبول وابراهيم منير لم يكن على تواصل
دائم وهمم وحتى مش على تواصل ابدا مع
اخوان مصر واخوان الداخل لهم من الاهميه
كذلك في هذا التنظيم فسؤال المطروح الى اي
مدى اساسا هو كشخصيه كان شخصيه مهمه همم
هل وفاته ستنهي شيئا من التنظيم ام ان
التنظيم انتهى حتى من قبل الوفاه وتفتت
همم كيف تقراين حضرتك هذا التطور
بيجاوب على النقطتين حضرتك تفضلتي فيها
ايش موقع ابراهيم منير
ووفاته ماذا ستحدث في الجماعه بالنسبه
ابراهيم منير لا شخصيه جدا مهمه تاريخيه
من من الصقور في الجماعه يعني كان سجن مع
سيد قطب في السجن همم رافق الجماعه في
مراحل جدا مهمه همم ايضا على انها كان في
في القياده العليا في جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين همم وكل رسميا بان يكون نائب
المرشد من قبل المرشد العام للجماعه
فهو شخصيه جدا مهمه اليوم همم قبل قليل
فقط كان في يعني حاليا في تركيا يقام
العزاء لابراهيم منير وحضرتك قيادات جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين من كل من السودان من
الجزائر من الدول العربيه همم
فكانت الكلمات جدا همم كبيره وزخم كبيره
لتعليات موقع ابراهيم منير وشارك في هذا
عبر الاتصال مرئي خالد مشعل همم من الدوحه
واطلع تزكيه كبيره جدا لابراهيم منير خلال
كلمته وذكر دوره في مساله نشات حركه حماس
وجهوده في هذا الاطار همم
يعني هل هذا يمكن اعتباره اول مؤشرات
التقارب بين جبه لندن وشبهه اسطنبول
تعتقدين همم
جبهه لندن ونعم هناك في في اسطنبول بعض
يعني من ذهب قليلا مع جبهه لندن يعني ليس
يعني ليست كل الاصوات لكن تتكلمي عن
الشخصيات التي
احدثت هذا الانشقاق محصوره في عدد يعني
يقال انهم 40 شخصيا لكن المهم في الجماعه
من هي الشخصيات التي هي الاكبر وعمر
والممارسه في الجماعه منذ زمن طويل بحيث
تعطي تعيد لحمه الجماعه من جديد ويبدو ان
القيادات
القديمه من الاثر العربيه تذهب مع ابراهيم
منير يعني بالنسبه لي انا قراتها من خلال
كلمه خالد مشعل في هذا الموضوع
واقاموا عده مجالس عزاء في الدوحه كمان
اقيم مجلس عزاء اقامه خالد
وشارك عن بعد في المجلس الاعزاء الذي كان
في اسطنبول
بالنسبه لوفاه طبعا هي مؤثره لان الجماعه
فقدت من فتره بسيطه يوسف القرضاوي واليوم
تفقد ابراهيم منير همم هذه القيادات طبعا
هي كبيره في العمر او لم يبقى لديهم
الكثير من القيادات التاريخيه يعني
بالنسبه لجبهه لندن نتكلم اااه على يعني
ثلاث شخصيات متبقيه منها محي الدين اللي
هو الاصبح اليوم وكل ما يشابه انه هو
ابراهيم منير من كلف ان يكون نائبه وحلمي
الجزار وكمال حشمت هذه يعني لكن فقط محي
الدين بجانب ابراهيم منير من كان في
التنظيم الخاص الجماعه الاخوان فهي هذه
الشخصياتتين بعدها مغادره ابراهيم منير
يبقى محي الدين همم من الشخصيات القديمه
والمهمه في التنظيم الخاص اما حلم الجزار
وكمال فهما في القياده العامه او في مجلس
الشورى الجماعه لكنهم لم يكونوا في
التنظيم نعم بالنسبه لاعمارهم في
السبعينات اه اليوم احنا بنشوف جماعه
الاخوان بعد تقريبا باقي لها شوي وتكمل
100 سنه
فنتكلم عن الجماعه بتمر في مرحله كهوله
وفي جيل جديد
بيساعد في هذه الجماعه طيب صباح الخير هذا
هذا يخدم الجماعه تكوينها تنظيمها همم
خليني اسال الاستاذ منير في هذا الاطار
واعود لكم هذا همم ما مستقبل الجماعه بعد
فتره من الكهوله هناك عمليات تشبيب فهل
ست- ستكون لصالحها او بعد تفتتها وبعد
انقسامات فيها قد يكون الموضوع مغير
يعني اذا كان الحديث عن ابراهيم منير
القائم باعمال مرشد الاخوان الذي توفى على
عتاب ال 85
عاما فان حركه الاخوان المسلمين ربما قربت
المئه عام وهي وصلت الى مرحله الشيخوخه
ولذلك كان عنوان المقال ايهما سبق وفاه
الاخر ابراهيم منير الذي بلغ 85 عاما ام
الجماعه التي وصلت الى المئه عام ولذلك
التنظيم رغم انه تنظيم كبير وممتد ووصل
الى قراب الثمانين دوله الا ان هذا
التنظيم الكبير اشبه بالجسد الكبير
الممتاز الذي اصبح بلا حرارات لا يستطيع
ان يحرك اعضائه وانصاره سواء داخل مصر في
الاحتجاجات التي دعا اليها هؤلاء
المتطرفون او حتى هو قادر على تحريك ربما
المجموعات التابعه له في الدول همم
المختلفه ولذلك نحن نقول اذا كان ذلك
يقول بان هذا التنظيم لن يكون كما كان في
المستقبل هو مكبل ولا لن يكون قادر على
الحركه على تحريك اعضاء خاصه
فتعتقدين بان هذه بدايه النهايه فعلا
طبعا هي ليست النهايه هو تنظيم له تجارب
كبيره في مع حركات كثيره من الاربعينيات
حتى الانشقاقات لم تكن جديده في في
الجماعه فكان قبلها في الشوقين في عهد
البناء وانا فسقوا البنا من ابناء البنا
انفسهم ثم جاء في حدود 54 وايضا في فتره
ال 65 حدثت الازمات للجماعه وايضا
انشقاقات في داخل الجماعه هنتكلم عن حتى
شخصيات كبيره منهم محمد الشيخ محمد
الغزالي شيخ الشعراوي وايضا الباقوري
مجموعه كبيره من الشخصيات المفكره في
الجماعه كانت همم خرجت من الجماعه يعني
نقدتها
وتحدثت كثيرا عنها لكن استمرت الجماعه
المهم هنا ان فقدان الشخصيات التاريخيه او
الكاريزماتيه لاي تنظيم ولاي جماعه حتى ما
تؤثر فيها وحتما تغير الجماعه اليوم مضطره
لتغير سياقاتها لان جيل شباب واصبح لا
يمشي ولا يفهم الفكر القديمه التي كانت
تمشي في جماعه الاخوان المسلمين وتقاد في
بطريقتها السريه وطريقه همم يعني الاثر
ال- ال- المتكتمه اصبح الشباب اكثر يريد
المشاركه ويريد ان يكون هو في الصوره يعني
ويريد ان يكون مشاركا
سيد همم منير اعذريني على مقاطع استاذ هدى
ولكن استاذ منير هل سيكون هذا اكثر اكثر
ان تكون هناك انشقاقات لمجموعات صغيره
يذكرنا ذلك بداعش وفيما بعد بدا بالمنفرده
في ما قبل كان ال ال ال يعني منظمه
الاخوان كانت هناك لوائح يعتمد هل الجميع
اليوم مجموعه من المجموعات المشتته سيكون
اخطر ذلك تعتقد
وقلنا ان الانقسامات التي حدثت وما زالت
موجوده داخل تنظيم الاخوان سواء كنا نتحدث
عن الجبهات الثالثه الثلاث جبهه لندن او
اسطنبول او حتى جبهه المكتب العام هي
انعكاس لانهيار التنظيم عندما قلنا ان
التنظيم الان على اجهزه التنفس الصناعي
كنا نقصد ان هذا التنظيم شاخذ ربما خلاياه
وقرب ربما على الانهيار الحقيقي لولا ان
التنظيم يحتاج الى تفكيك الافكار المؤسسه
حتى لا نرى التنظيم بعد ذلك ولذلك نقول ان
هذا الانقسام هو اا دلاله ربما على سقوط
التنظيم واعتقد بعد وفاه الابراهيميه لم
يعد لم يعد الانتساب فقط على الجبهات
الثلاث بينما
الاستاذه هدى صالح الكاتبه الصحفي شكرا
جزيلا لكم كما قلت للنقاش دائما بقيه
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]